[Music]
despite its volatility and serious
environmental concerns cryptocurrency
mining is ramping up at a breakneck pace
causing the network to inevitably grow
worldwide
in april of 2021 prominent members of
the community created the crypto climate
accord
inspired by the paris climate accord
their stated goal is to decarbonize
bitcoin mining and other cryptocurrency
energy consumption
[Music]
as signatories of the accord new york
city's bitdigital is doing their part to
practice what they preach while keeping
their eye on the bottom line we're bit
digital we're a bitcoin mining company
and we are
sitting in our new office just off union
square in new york city
reusing sustainable energy sources is
clearly the right thing to do from the
perspective of the planet
and i'm an environmentalist at heart so
that's something i personally care about
in terms of our bottom line it's
important because it's something our
investors care about increasingly
institutional investors are very focused
on compliance with esg goals and we're a
publicly traded company so that's
something we have to be
very thoughtful about
it is an energy-intensive industry
and so it's incumbent on us as a company
and others in the community
to find ways to source that energy that
aren't going to
add to the carbon footprint
so i actually graduated with my master's
degree in civil and environmental
engineering from carnegie mellon
university it's actually my first time
applying what i've learned from school
in real life yeah we have about 46 000
miners across the globe and we estimate
about 55
on renewable or low carbon energy and
we're setting targets to increase them
percentage
but to understand how we're gonna have
to leave their manhattan we work office
and head to a more remote corner of the
country
these co-locations as they're called
service bitcoin mining and other
cryptocurrency computing needs
so right now we're in kearney nebraska
and we're standing on a bitcoin mining
facility it's running about 60 megawatts
of power
and there's about 20 000 individual
bitcoin mining computers in this
facility
can't hear a damn thing in here
we have about 5 000 of these so about a
quarter of these are ours
so those solar panels on the in the next
field that's a part of the generation
capacity that's ultimately powering this
facility right yeah correct so that is
actually the largest solar field in all
of nebraska so 65
of the electricity that comes into our
facility here at compute north
is carbon free
just in the last you know several weeks
to several months though the the demand
has certainly outstripped our ability to
uh supply and to scale at the level that
they need we have had to turn clients
away
[Music]
even though the the scale and the size
of the bitcoin network is is getting
massive i think the easiest thing to
attack is the energy and the the amount
and usage
candidly i could say the same thing for
facebook i'm not a fan of the social
media network i'm not a fan of my
neighbors cat photos i mean they also
use a tremendous amount of energy
i think bitcoin is very different in
that what it is energy intensive it also
can go to places where that energy would
otherwise not be put to use there's more
energy not being used at all and simply
goes to waste than bitcoin even uses by
a factor of 20.
[Music]
this is true primarily because of a
concept called stranded energy which is
essentially power that's generated but
due to grid limitations can't be used
and ultimately goes to waste
crypto miners are now flocking to
co-location sites to make use of this
stranded energy and stranded energy by
its nature is in remote places
this bitcoin mining it is an economic
animal and it's going to seek the lowest
economic cost power it can find that is
often stranded renewables that don't
have any other users available because
nature puts renewable energy wherever
nature chose to put it computers and
bitcoin miners don't care where they
live you can literally put them anywhere
in the world west texas has abundant
wind resources
northern quebec there are miners
operating up there on the hydropower
that's abundant there solar farms
sitting in the middle of a desert and so
we've brought the computational demand
to where the renewable power is located
by bit digital's own estimate however 45
percent of the power their machines draw
remains from non-renewables like oil and
gas to mitigate the environmental
effects of these less carbon neutral
energy sources they've come up with some
innovative solutions i have a
partnership in alberta canada with a
company that develops mining sites that
sit on top of dormant natural gas wells
and they are venting natural gas into
the atmosphere instead of venting that
natural gas which is mostly methane into
the atmosphere
it's being captured and repurposed to
create energy to run bitcoin mining and
by doing that and converting it into
fuel
it actually reduces the emissions the
greenhouse gas emissions of that gas
still eco-conscious miners do need to go
even further in order to curb their
power consumption however mining
machines don't need to run 24 hours a
day seven days a week like other more
critical networks
and miners like bit digital have
agreements with their power providers to
curtail usage during peak demand when
there is grid needs when there's a
better use for the energy when there's a
great emergency we can and we do shut
down and that's a very key part of our
whole mantra of being not just a good
citizen locally but being a good citizen
to the energy into the power networks
but without worldwide enforceable
regulations efforts like this could very
well be in vain
if mining remains this lucrative there
will always be people that put profit
over planet which gives the more
conscientious miners all the more reason
to get machines out of the regions of
the world with less regulations and into
areas with better transparency and
accountability
about a mile away there's a warehouse
that's full of a bunch that we recently
flew over from china
[Music]
and you know frankly uh it's not great
to see them sitting here in boxes
because they could be plugged in and
making money and i want to get them out
and making some money as quickly as
possible
all the miners as you see today are
actually manufactured
and designed by chinese companies
and going from there it's a process of
distributing all those miners across the
globe to make it more you know
decentralized and that's exactly what we
are doing here we're as a minor to
support the bitcoin network depending on
the model and the exact moment you buy
them are going to cost 10 to 15 000 a
piece
and um
it's kind of like a souped-up ps5
you plug it in and it starts making this
commodity we know as bitcoin
bitcoin has
had a bit of a democratizing effect
people can actually create pretty
attractive returns for themselves
without having a whole lot of money to
put to work
you know that was enabled by bitcoin and
now it's spread to a bigger ecosystem
to bitcoin devoutees that ecosystem as
energy intensive as it may be has the
potential to be less harmful to the
environment than other more traditional
forms of stored value
what's really striking about this moment
is
for the first time really in human
history
we've got a truly global
asset class
that is in many ways like gold it's a
store of value with a fixed supply and
you can create it with the sun
i'd rather see a bunch of robots using
energy from the sun
to mint bitcoins versus gold
using human beings and burning fossil
fuels and stripping open mountaintops to
mine gold
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you